what's your reaction to what you heard
from the Prime Minister today
setting out his stall first time he's
been at CBI yeah I mean grateful for the
stability the message of stability I
mean clearly that was the intent of the
Autumn statement last week and I think
that the Prime Minister backed that up
with some interesting comments around
the focus on growth uh innovation
technology that's what we're all sort of
waiting for here to kick start the
economy and do our piece to to to to
ignite growth again how necessary is
that stability message given if we've
been having this conversation six five
six weeks ago felt like a very different
kind of a different prime minister and
Chancellor well it really did I mean you
know we we outlined an investment
package just five months ago of 25
billion pounds and the one thing I said
was you know we really need a stable
fiscal environment in order to make sure
that we can get that that investment out
the door and since then we've had three
uh three budgets a couple of prime
ministers so you know it's welcome news
to see the stability part of that
stability
raising taxes
cutting spending with the raising taxes
is built on a windfall tax an increased
windfall tax precisely on companies like
yours what is your view of the fairness
of that the appropriateness of that and
will it affect how you make investment
decisions yeah look we are you know as
the UK's biggest company uh we we need
to do our part so so we understand the
need that is out there and I think we
understand the nature of the windfall
tax however you know the current design
of the windfall tax doesn't have a an
off switch it doesn't have a price point
at which that windfall tax turns off and
I think you know that was something that
we would like to be talking to the
government further about